[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
of the best scholastic players from st.
Louis chess club take on eight of the
very best from Zug Diddy chess school in
the nation of Georgia last year the
margin was razor thin four and a half to
three and a half to clinch the match st.
Louis had the victory but today so did
he
they're back and they're angry they're
hungry they want revenge against these
eight competitors you see before you in
the world famous st. Louis chess club
tournament hall and today it's gonna be
a lot of action one round winner take
all
first a four and a half is the victor so
come on in to the studio and join us for
a while
hello chess fans Bensimon here along
with the most entertaining man in chess
Mike comer once again Mike are you
pumped for today oh yeah I've been
waiting for this for a year they've been
they've been bugging me all all six
months and just saying hey we got a play
we got a plan I said fine let's do it
Easter weekend can't wait see if they
can raise from the dead the big return
match on the Internet
before we get started let's take a look
at the roster that zug diddy chess
school is fielding all the way over in
europe we have your gaku collage really
Jorgy na copia Nicola Nicola Z Shama
tava
Georgie sartania who by the way is the
only returning player from their field
last year Maya Beck via and Gregori beg
via Nika at Kim ilaria and Dimitri and
two lava now these are these players all
have feed a ratings and it's interesting
to note I think about half of the field
from st. Louis has feeder ratings the
other half of course has us Ches ratings
but once again this year by the numbers
only
we are outmatched in every match Mike
what do you think about that it's all
good we got our whole returning a roster
coming back
that of course won last year so let's
take a look don't mean no right and we
proved them wrong last year IRAs out our
captain who did such a great job last
year Ashish Ponda one of the club
regulars he goes to all the lectures
Alexander in Lynn Aiden Wong pardon me
Aiden Wong Salinas out who is iris
little sister Numan Shen and Adi panda
what do you have to say about this field
here Mike
well iris our captain recently won the
2019 Missouri scholastic state
championship doesn't have the same ring
as the 1998 Missouri scholastic state
champion but it's still a heck of an
accomplishment and I'm thinking she's
gonna lead the team to victory once
again this year so the games are going
on right now on leach s org let's take a
look at our format we have one round
eight games going on at the same time
it's unrated over the Internet friendly
unrated eight versus eight our board one
faces their board one all the way down
the line so on and so forth
all of the games are worth one point so
with eight points on the line the first
four and a half clinches the match in
the event of a 4-4 tie the match will be
a draw there will be no playoff the
games are game in 25 with a ten-second
increment so let's waste no more time
let's get to the action Mike with our
board one oh right so iris has the black
pieces against their team captain
Georgie so let's see how this game /
seeds
all rightie for c5 the sicilian knight
c3 so when they play this they could be
going into the grand prix attack so
usually I play a six here just stop any
potential nonsense but instead they
decide to get their Bishop the n-channel
here
so iris does the same
e5 I really don't like this move by iris
because it really weakens the d5 square
keep in mind I am a 1700 and I am not
using a computer so take all my analysis
with a grain of salt and I'm a 1500 and
I'm not using but I might cheat from
time to time all right we might need it
Knight h3 hey but by the way before we
continue I've got to tell you guys if
you want to follow these games live on
leaches org the simplest way to do it is
to extend the description on the YouTube
video all of the st. Louis players
screen names that they're playing under
today are on leech s orb just going
search for the names open up those eight
tabs that's what we're doing so join in
on the fun all right that's all I got to
say excellent okay so iris continues her
development I guess they're both looking
to uh to Castle but okay so he brings
out the old f4 here so iris has two
options either take it or d6 all right
so she chooses d6 castles castles so I
don't know so even though White has a
more advanced pawns here
I think his King's pretty safe while
iris might be having some trouble here
let's see 9f - all right continued
development
g4 very very ambitious so threatening f5
here so designers have to take she does
take back Knight e5 threatening the
gee-pole and putting more pressure on it
obviously Georgie has two defenders and
that's where we are right now so I'm
gonna give an edge to two white here but
nothing that iris can't overcome I mean
you know white should theoretically have
the the upper hand you know after the
opening so a slight edge for white all
right so long to the next game here
all right Ashish panda as white taking
on your gain that copia alright the
board's already flipped I like it yeah
it's nice how that works
everything's working in our favor today
it's at the d-35 so so what she decides
to take it there is Ashish right there
night eat too so she's just not trying
to blow this guy you know off the board
or anything so I guess that's okay
you know with such a passive opening
that the guy was playing maybe maybe he
could have tried it
you're not about those passive openings
- no no no I would have I would have
just right I would have gone right after
well Bishop d3 is okay but after you
find I would have played d5 and kept
going but alright so h3 you see this in
a lot of high-level Grandmaster games
now they always have to get their h3 h6
in it's like mandatory you know they
both decided we can take a move off to
get look for King stop all the bishop
pin nonsense so you see that in a lot of
a high level just now Bishop e3 all
right oh so okay so if she's just like
their board one you know the little
delayed attack on move 10 just go for
that f4 stuff I like this move right
here I think I would play off for in
this position yeah I like it too
I like it too so so does he have to take
it
arge Clark maybe he can play Bishop to
d6 here Knight d7 looks too slow okay
but that's what he does play
unbelievable well you wouldn't want to
take the F pawn right I mean cuz then
you just got that Bishop on f4 staring
at the Queen there right that looks
dangerous then you then you throw in a
check if after pawn takes Bishop takes
you got the big check so the Kings under
attack and the b-pawn is under attack
so maybe I mean I would I would have
suspected Ashish would have taken back
with the bishop but he's got to look out
for those uh forks
all right so f5 I like it I like it all
right so now look desperate times I mean
this guy's already in desperate measures
here so he's just trying to get
counterplay on the other side but all
the action and the king the nine billion
dollar king is on this side so sheesh
just let them let him do his little
attack well I mean mighty plays a three
then the knight won't be under attack so
so Ashish could just play Queen to d2
here and then let them have this pitiful
little b4 move and then just play Knight
d1 9f2
and reroute this Knight to the King side
and just let him do whatever he thinks
he's doing on the Queen side but as
she's too slow too slow too slow one of
the things I can say positive about
Ashish right here is that one early on
you want your attack to be pointed you
want your pawns to be pointed toward the
opponent's king they want to push that
way and that's what he has here and I
like it you know what you were getting
at was a you know putting the Queen on
d2 but still now we have a bishop
pinning the bishop on the e3 to the king
right you can't do that so what now
so what now we do now Mike save me what
to do what to do
probably Queen to d2 is probably the
best here you know well look at this
he's just piling on piling on now very
sad state of affairs rook f3 will go a
nice rook left takes he's gonna take
back with the oh so Wow so wow so so as
she she's attack is all but vanished its
fizzling yeah basically 95i beautiful
move
I mean you would never trade this night
this beautiful night on c5 for this
hopeless hopeless Bishop look at this
bishop have you ever seen as more
senator three-point piece it's one of
those times when the bishop is
definitely not worth more than an act
right now not even much more than a
Pollock yeah please come on come get the
bishop and that's a good move well he
could still she could still play d4 here
which it looks like he is going to play
but this is this is this is falling
apart for a sheet here so is he really
gonna play Knight 82 or work to be one I
would play rook to be one in this
position okay good and that's where we
stand so sad to stay this guy has
definitely equalized if not better
mr. Georgie they got double Georgie's
carrying their boards one and two and
all right so let's go to let's go let's
see if we got some good news with
alexengel assed time yes
zhang has black against Nicolosi Shama
tava so even though Alex sang is st.
Louis and four he moved up a board from
last year so he's just using his same
account yes okay okay so what are easy
to understand this naming scheme but I
don't want you want you to think oh why
why are is our fourth guy playing their
third guy you know but now we know all
right
Oh Alex why didn't you just Castle and
and in this position I know he might
want to say oh well book is d6 maybe but
d5 seems a little more ambitious because
he hasn't been challenging with c4 c4 I
probably would have just Castle but okay
it's it's still all good for this guy so
okay so is he going to break with E 5 RC
5 all right okay a couple castle first
hey II five or c5 now that's Now or
Never
oh sorry so he didn't take and he didn't
play d5 so now he can capture if need be
said they get to h6 move in which is
fine he gets out of the pin ooh
now the rook is on the same line as the
Queen this is this is not the best night
h5 what is he thinking about here well
it's hard to tell because he looks like
one of the Dementors from Harry Potter
we've got a lot of sunlight coming in
it's a nice sunny brisk day here in st.
Louis yeah we were supposed to have that
we were supposed to only have that open
for like two minutes he is real very
minute very menacing and so it now looks
like white plays right into his hand
here this this I cannot believe if I was
white I almost be tempted to play g4 and
say what you got cuz I just do not
understand the threat here but I mean
look at this move who is his opponent
Nicole Z I mean he just just letting
them trade dead Bishop for the night
that that confounds me okay
I don't understand well I mean do you
think that black can initiate an attack
on the h-file
No so I mean that would take way too
long so he paid King age seven rook H a
king g8 and then I don't know how I'm
gonna get my Queen to the H file all
right so he's almost tempting him to
play d5 here I would have much rather
played my Bishop to g4 oh and now he's
like take my pawn obviously we would
never take the pawn on a tube why not
mine how's Abby oh yeah but I can see
that tactic so alexengel not fall for it
and really this guy really hasn't done
anything to make the rook and the Queen
on the same Lane you know detriment to
them
oh now Bishop to g4 a little late a
little late a little late Queen East 7
so threatening captures and then Queen
to d2 maybe and that's where we are here
alex is doing just fine
so so that that's a positive news for
Team st. Louis yeah yeah yeah for sure
so let's go to ok and next up is Erin
Lin ok lane white against gurgi star
Tanya the only player to return to suck
Diddy's team this year
oh very interesting very interesting
where is it Georgie so they they like
him here we got a typical Sicilian here
he five I hate when people like I play
the Sicilian a bunch I never ever in my
life play e5 why do you hate it so much
because it leaves black with a backwards
D pawn and a big hole on d5 where I can
just jump my knight it like all I'm
gonna do now is I'm gonna trade my dark
square Bishop for this night and
hopefully it's just play you know get my
knight on d5 and just
just roll you over but let's see let's
see how it goes oh my gosh are you good
well he's got to put his knife back on a
three now huh it's not ideal
so b5 should be played by black yes good
alright so everybody sees the sees the
threat Ryan Chester would not want you
to get for it okay that pawn pork is the
most embarrassing force of all cuz it's
almost like you did it to yourself
you know so what do you do do you just
take it all I know you jumping in the d5
good good jump in it so Bishop e7 so
capture East seven probably well so in
this position I really like capturing
the bishop here and then Queen takes you
still have the pin on and then just
reroute this Knight via B 1 C 3 D 5 and
then still have the pin going well yeah
but what happens I mean after you plant
b1 then before we can do a she she's a
three all right all right so all these
trades did not help did not help Aaron
Lynn let's get let's get a closer shot
of Aaron Lynn if we can because he's
actually in one of the well-lit parts of
the room upstairs yeah see his reaction
well look everyone's having a good time
all right yes party party party he's
like getting on the move c3 okay so you
can get this night c2 to e3 to d5 okay
we have a plan we have a plan
Oh Queens on the same land as the rook
again they must have been really
teaching that it's like that's like city
school f3 almost has to be played here
but we don't even want to play up to me
we could play Bishop f3
hopefully he plays Bishop f3 okay good
good good good good good
it's way better than f3 yep
see that's not a well it is a threat
because now he's got two men hitting he
4 and he's only got one defender so
Queen to c2 Queen to c2 it looks good
but then he'll play rook to c8 you know
keeping the rook on the same line so
let's see what's actually played and
here we go oh and it castles right into
it puts everybody on so everybody knows
what move Black is gonna play here
before and now the time the e4 yeah well
he's this dancer he doesn't even kiss is
it hopeless though I mean that can we
follow with b3 for white and next move
hold the pawn at bay any hope so c4 so
let's see what we got so let's see how
can a black purse seed here he could
play a 5 so when b3 happens see if we
have anything more ambitious
I would just push the pawn right a five
that's that's what that's what I would
do as as black here and then we can uh
we can see how that was first seeds but
yet so so I'm definitely liking uh like
Diddy again but significant out to a big
big start last year as well and you know
team st. Louis obviously prevailed you
know Aaron Aaron unfortunately got
checkmated early on in the in the
session so looking like it could go the
same way so let's go to is this okay
so that would be Aiden with the black
pieces and let's see what he can do
alright so we have not seen this yet oh
yeah war Lopez not the exchange
variation so you know how I feel about
that well that's okay Mike I have to
double-check here something I don't want
to make sure I got the board's in order
so we just looked at Aaron late I was
the fourth board he was the fourth board
and so now we're an eighth in this game
is this correct aiden is the fifth board
correct yes okay I'm mytabs we're out of
order apollon yes yes yes but it's so
Aiden Wong as black versus Maya Beck via
so castle castle I mean they're probably
they win a theory I would imagine now
they're just rewriting their Knights
nothing really spectacular here going on
I don't know what that was ideal for
Aiden was he afraid he was gonna lose
something cuz he just gave himself an
isolated D pawn it looks like he didn't
really have to
before a now he's back going back Knight
f5 okay alright
take that who Bishop g5 looks good here
rule nine to five is good to f4 and now
he's coming for him all right
but he's got a nice little outpost there
so he attacks the night prime brick c8
work the da rook to d8 all right well
yeah you got it okay okay okay so it was
the guy was threatening Bishop takes
Knight
you know pawn takes our queen takes its
removing the defender so good good for
a8 him he saw the star the attack okay
so why didn't he move the other room
okay so it maybe didn't want to remove
the defender of f7 and maybe wants to
put his other work on v8 instead of c8
in the future all right I can't I can't
be mad about that
lots of pressure coming on lots of
pressure and you know this guy might
have is that still good it's good right
here okay okay good you might actually
have plans down the line of knight takes
g7 here as well as as weird as it sounds
cuz you can push the epon yeah you pawn
and then you never know what could
happen I mean it doesn't work right now
but but just look out for plans of that
kind of stuff now he throws in a
meaningless check
so okay so so a follow up here would be
Knight to g4 possibly trying to get a
little counter-attack going with Knight
F to check followed by a potential
smothered mate you know the famous
smother mate if he plays King up Chuck
and no it doesn't even work it doesn't
work and now look at this now he puts
the rook back on c8 so now he's he's
through what's the goodies there to us
all all day long put that rook on on the
same line as the Queen gives some
discovered attacks go in and see what
can happen I notice a lot of these
players are moving up and about through
the board room are they allowed to talk
to each other and ask for advice I know
the only time they are allowed to ask
for advice is to ask the team captain
iris sau if they should take a draw
unlike last year we are making them
write down their result on a piece of
paper so iris can just take a quick
glance at that not at their board but at
just the result sheet and then she can
proceed from there whether or not they
should take a draw based on the match
score and not any position correct yes
okay yes all right let's head on to it
so so all right so so Aidan and look
Aiden does have a lead in the time now
the time is becoming a factor even
though they do have that ten-second
increment so he's getting a little a
little momentum going I would I would
assume just maybe move that Queen to b1
or something here or maybe
counter-attack with a 5 let's see how it
goes all right let's go to the sixth
word this this looks like it's winding
down I don't know if we want to go
through the whole game or yes Selina's
al versus grig Oh Beck via you know this
Beck via family they filled in a few
players this year and last year I'm not
sure exactly how they're related
probably siblings but
Selina yeah already in an endgame a few
of the games started a little bit
earlier on before we got on the air so
one of them some people found that found
how to accept their challenge faster
than others that's why there's a
discrepancy Selina was one of the first
ones and was telling everybody done
shut up basically I don't care why if
you can find your buns or not I'm
playing so just cool it everybody as
Selena is a little under the weather
today so she's got a built-in excuse it
looks like she's pounding those sprites
back though so maybe I'll put some more
pep in her check oh yes why did you
allow that check why didn't when do you
check like that why didn't you just go
to g2 instead of allowing another check
that's not cool
maybe she wants maybe she wants her King
in the center alright well we'll see
we'll see it but I wonder if in this
position extra oh I guess I guess you
can't because your knight is under
attack
okay all right so all right Selina's get
that past deep pond so she's wasting no
time you know some people would be
cautious and just use that as like you
know are golden and endgame that past
deep on but she just wants it right away
so let's see if it uh and it better home
she just lost it
oh right Bishop takes Hey look at that
you got a pain you're gonna make sure
well you gave up it she gave up an
extent exchanged though I think you yeah
but yeah but to get it right back she
gave up her her precious D pawn okay
Chuck so night Ryan the king away or
trying to in here
so now Selena let's see if she's really
good and see if she can play g4 no even
better even better putting the pressure
he bores a little slow anyway cuz black
of course Pinewood g5 but who I mean
with all these exchanges oh so she
probably needs to prepare g4 with h4 and
this this is just almost unacceptable at
her level is trading app in peace taking
app in peace why does she have to take
it exactly as a she doesn't why you know
why are we right right because what
black all he can move is pawns
right can't move the knight can't move
the king or else you just lose can't
move this rook or else rook takes check
and then you lose the rook because the
rook can't take back
so rate Selena should have just taken
the pawn I can't believe and now look
now now black can move any well keep you
move the knight now very very
disheartening that this this exchange
but luckily blacks just playing along
just Len look like something to take
everything anyway so that's nice
there you go now just push the other
point and see what happens so I would
imagine a Selena will protect this pawn
somehow or give a check first okay so
okay Celina I mean as disheartening as
that one exchange was she's still up by
two pawns but this is by no means just
flat-out winning especially with her you
know
Antonis to push these pawns to to either
you know queen or to oblivion so
hopefully she'll get a queen out of one
of these but it's not looking very good
so she's got to play Pilate Bishop f3 or
d3
Bishop d3 looks more ambitious because
then you're targeting this pawn but with
Bishop f3 you see targeting the knight
targeting the knight and protecting that
queening square so this is when we
almost do need like grandmaster or chess
engine to see which is better Bishop d3
or f3 while they look you know like who
cares I'm protecting my pony either way
it could go a long way to really
deciding whether this game is a win or a
drill alright so let's go to number
eight or we're on 7 I believe Newman
Shambo Newman says black against Anika
Kimmel Arya okay let's go to number
seven okay totally opposite look all the
pawns are still on the board and only
one set of minors has been traded off so
Newman so this is a deep or opening
we're trying to kind of buzz through
this as you know other games might be
come into to fruition and it doesn't
really look like there's much fireworks
on this one yes 60 now this is the this
is the absolute last game that got
started cuz Newman had a little trouble
with his uh getting this button going
but it looks like look at look at a huge
time advantage almost 11 to 5 you know
so that's that's good for Newman Newman
was up a bunch of time last year
if you recall but then lost in that
drawn Bishop ending unfortunately okay
so hopefully uh Newman will have a
better result this year it looks like
he's doing just fine
like nobody really has an advantage
the biggest advantage right now is the
time alright so let's go to Auntie panda
who we did not get to see last year but
he was victorious and look at look at
Oddie's time this is we might be able to
see thee see the very end of this one
yeah Adi is playing Dimitri Anton LaVey
this is our board eight but remember all
of the games are weighted exactly the
same one point so this is just as
important as any other game Adi probably
is the most consistent Club number two
all of our classes I think he's at every
single one yep and it shows because he
plays the opening really really well so
no look look unlike other kids well we
haven't really seen that too much where
they're trained to just crush each other
right right off the bat you know he
plays a conservatively gets castled
and he's gonna get his pieces out like
his brother he plays a three in this
position I actually wish he would have
played on each three to prevent Bishop
to g4 but but that's okay so it all
worked out in the end he got some extra
tempo so now he plays d4 and Adi knows
this opening well so that's why he's got
such a huge time advantage
Knight f5 ah he does watch a lot of FN
Feingold videos as well so gotta get
that Knight f5 in there reroutes is
Bishop to the h7 diagonal here Wow
tactics tactics tactics tactics so I
can't take back he left the back row
takes but now he's got it
well well he's got a tactic of his own
but maybe it's pin city Mike it's pin
city city of Logan something slightly
more fun than spatula see it's going way
back that's you H yeah
spatula City that's a weird al' yankovic
will be with kramer as the janitor the
crazy janitor check it out
oh now look at this big attack is this
is this approaching the end because now
we see the Jeep on is still pinned here
against the king in the corner so okay
but then you play Knight h7 then we
would play e5 and we'd have the bishop
and the Queen attacking if Queen took
the pawn but obviously he plays Queen to
e6 here so so now we can't play that but
we might just play e5 anyway
mm what about just like home oh oh he
can't play f4 because of uh we're like
just King H one King H 1 and then f4 and
just f5 and just kill this guy you know
I'd be down for that yeah that's but
Bishop d2 I know I know what the threat
is I can just take you and then you
can't take back huh huh huh well Mike
actually you know you were talking about
King H wanted to prep for F but the F
pawn is hanging so then the bishop could
just take straight away yeah there goes
our attack there it goes
that's why I D does not listen to me ooh
but look at this triple pause Oh
whenever you can give a man triple pawns
just do it oh no oh no Mike oh we have a
result not yet but it looks like it's
imminent Selena is in trouble against
griilll on board 6 the endgame did not
pan out for her and this pawn is about
to promote the game may actually already
be over it says white resigned black is
victorious all right well first blood
goes to Greg Obadiah and Selena had 2
extra pots remember and she had it where
the opponent couldn't even move so what
happened here so in this position we
were saying Bishop d3 or f3 chose
neither oh and she got for it
well this night night here just straight
up wins right that looks like it yeah
you can do instead he got the pulling
gets out of the way Wow so white in this
position should just play rook back and
and I mean and just take the draw
because okay Knight takes rook takes
rook takes a four draw but so the King
moved to d1 is that right and the knight
takes Bishop she should probably realize
oh look can't take rook cuz there's
another fork there I see I was like oh
the black rook is hanging it's not
hanging then I can reclaim with a fork
on c3 yeah okay
so very very very very disheartening
Selina had a we can go back to the dream
position one more time she had the dream
and she let him off the hook in this
position never ever take this rook just
take the pawns make it so this guy can
never move and you should be victorious
but got a little antsy and Kregel wins
let's take a look back at board number
one Mike because IRAs ours in time
trouble against the captain of the zag
ditty team your gig cuca wash really so
what has happened since the last time we
looked at this game I think this is
where we went off right chief of they
protects the night Nate's coming into d5
well I mean it looks like b5 unprotect
the night so we got to watch out gotta
watch out
takes doubles the pawn but that's a nice
double play now c4 well okay Bishop
takes pawn takes why would you break the
chain here and now White has an advanced
deep on here see
c4 is just crying to be played but maybe
maybe white still wants that now closed
for the night
h6 I'm not a fan of h6 why in the world
are you opening opening lines for the
white attacker here alright but but
luckily she got it through get it there
okay now finally c4 okay alright so so
iris has a nice outpost for the knight
on d6 here but 96 should be instant you
know is this the live position yes okay
yes so you see iris is opponent has
seven to one advantage it's gonna be
really tough for iris to move basically
you could play rook e7 rook f8 and just
move back and forth like that but
there's no real there's no real plan
here for iris she just wants to survive
somehow some way it looks like st. Louis
is doing a little bit better on the
bottom boards than the top boards right
now okay well just give me a give me a
winner Ben sighs okay look at her that's
it let me try to cheer you up
Hey look at this Neumann Shen Board
number seven is black he's got Nica on
the ropes timewise ten to one ratio
there all right King up three let's see
let's see what what's happened since so
we got some trades in since since this
last position
in here this is about when we left off I
got a pawn got another pawn so it
literally looked like he really got a
let go and then yeah you're up trade
Knight takes pawn bishop Shaco he could
even block with uh Bishop b5 here and he
does all right good job
hey well just move whatever you want to
do I would not play that okay that's the
check I would play alright so let's see
all right Newman could still get castle
but ya know I'm not a big fan of
castling and endgame I would probably
play in this position maybe just bishop
no so this night won't what I'm thinking
is that the V file is controlled by
white right now so I just have this
compulsion to get the H rule out if I'm
black so if I'm not gonna Castle because
the King is you know shouldn't be hiding
away in the corner in the endgame maybe
I want to bring the King up to d7 yeah I
mean ideally I want to play yeah so this
is probably the way to go because if he
plays rook to be b7 right now has to do
the been fine go trick where I'll I'll
just move my bishop or Knight back and
it's now it's trapped it's trapped on b7
you see if he plays rook to b7 I can
just put either my bishop or my knight
there oh and now he's he's done he's
done all right so now Newman should just
take the b8 move his king to d7 put his
other book on c8 and lights out you're
done so this is it
just play work the b8 or you can even
play King d7 now but the irony great
Burke the BA all right so so Newman
Newman is gonna win this game
I alright so this is good all right what
else we got what else we got let's look
at Aaron son boy all right Aaron Lynn on
board number 4
he's playing a straight-up blitz game
right now two minutes to three minutes
against our Tanya all right so Aaron had
white oh remember last time we checked
in he just canceled into the into the
attack okay
and of course he played b4 c4 okay we
saw this all right so now we at least he
got off they'll file their a5 which was
I was Burke amending Knight d5 Knight
takes pawn takes
okay now I'm uneasy I wasn't before
oh I'm uneasy I don't like this and
Aaron is not smiling for the first time
as like either so that's always a bad
sign it looks a little aloof hello well
you got to think that maybe e4 is coming
from black okay who gives a little
attack going okay so we should be for
Bishop before visit before has to be
played why oh if the Queen takes why
didn't they instantly play Queen takes F
well okay but he wants to prepare it see
in this position why not just come down
and just take it I'm looking for a way
for white to make black pay with the
rooks
okay so let's say he does play Queen or
worked up one well didn't you move the
pieces are you so Richie - so he
protects it so this is almost anybody's
game now one two three four five six so
you know he didn't play a five right
away
this gentleman Georgie I should have
guessed that 8 a 5 a 4 you know to
prevent any kind of B 3 and just try to
try to win like that so now so now he
should reroute his rook to probably c8
here and then if white plays b3 play a4
and you still have some chances so
White's plan is probably to double up on
the G file here and Aaron's got some
chances who cares
now can you pre move on this on this
platform on LI chess I don't see why not
if you Capri moving a woman a game you
can pre move enough rapid game okay I
admittedly I don't play on Lee chess too
much but I know that it's picking up
steam and I mean just two years ago man
like Glee chess was just like oh yeah I
playing Lee chess what's that that's
that website it's kind of like gray you
know as some feature it's kind of cool
and now Lee chess is like all the rage
like everyone's planning on leech s so
very cool for them and like everything
is free so you should definitely check
that out if you haven't checked out Lee
chess org
be three yep all right here they are
blitzing out some moves the rook on c5
is a little bit useless right now would
you agree to play a five here as as
black trying to make make it look not so
useless I mean a five is just screaming
to be played in that position instead
he's gonna reroute his rook to f7 so
okay for a four-point yeah yeah black
should have played a four in this
position targeting the b-pawn and then
obviously if it takes I get the C pawn I
don't expect it him to take right and
then Aaron might have played King to be
one and then then you have an option of
chucking or taking so it looks like he's
just gonna double his rooks you know to
protect this pawn here okay oh you want
some good news Mike Newman Shen Board
seven let's do it as black he is in the
driver's seat he's tying up his opponent
nikka looks good one two three four five
pawns the three yeah yeah yeah we almost
have this one in the books good job for
us and it's almost mate look at this cuz
if that Knight moves then rook e6 that's
mate isn't it yep and you can't even
sacrifice your rook for the forecheck oh
but that got rid of the because now King
the d4 is an issue but let's see yeah so
after King to b5 Oh after King to b5 now
he's got the real Chuck I don't even
think that's very good cuz then I just
played King to see King to b6 and now
both your pieces are under attack
we have a result as ugh Diddy number
five
Ayden Wong's opponent has flagged and so
that means that st. Louis gets its first
point as Ayden Wong beats Maya Beck via
so good job Adan date in the winners
second year in a row aid in the winner
hey comes to play in these team
competitions good job all right Joe
right now the score is you can see right
there
Team USA the st. Louis chess club won
two Zach did HS school won the first
four and a half is the winning team won
one all right good good job good job
[Music]
okay so let can we go back to Newman's
game for just a moment
you want to feel win you win I feel like
I thought we might be close the night is
out of the way though there's no mate it
looks like anymore and okay so so Newman
says let's trade rooks and then I'll
force my opponent to trade his night for
the b-pawn hmm isn't it a solid idea I
would have just gone all the way to
today and just won the Jeep on and that
way I have a past H pawn but maybe it
was afraid of something like rook the c8
followed by rook to f8 so if he can say
oh well okay so now he forces the rook
trade right because because right if you
play rook to d4 you get checkmated
remember so yes all right
so let's see so so remember Selena she
was a little anxious pushing all those
pawns so let's see if if Newman can make
these guys pay off into a queen all
right we have some news once again weeds
up Diddy in the driver's seat on board
three a checkmate on the board as Alex
Zhang falls to Nicola
zishe amitabha checkmate in the corner
look at that checkmate of the coal downa
where is that bishop going where was
that bishop going
nice motif by niccolò Zi making it one
to two teams like did it yeah and once
again if you're watching these games on
LI chess or you see the clocks right
there with each move they do gain ten
seconds it's a ten second increments
started with 25 minutes so you could
play on this increment okay you could be
down to one second then to eleven as
long as you don't hit zero you're gonna
be okay let's see what again we have
another result on board eight the game
between Adi Panda and Dmitry until Allah
is drawn our first draw of the day zouk
diddy leads two and a half to one and a
half now it's like did he might just be
in draw mode cuz a draw drawn each board
produces a win for them you get two four
and a half year the winner so we got one
and a half two and a half
okay so as I'm just skimming for results
it's got all these tabs open so Aaron
has 49 seconds and looks like he's get
everything under wraps here so this
should be a draw it's I mean I don't see
how either side can really break through
here I mean the first thing I looked at
was pushing the c-pawn to try to break
through with D but yeah it doesn't look
sustainable really right because you got
no no rooks really backing it up your
Brooks are tied down to your H and F
puns you're the last thing you want to
do is give the man a pawn and then tie
your rooks down to another pulling so so
hopefully Eric can just move king e to
King III King e to King III King you to
King III and I just call it a day but
this does the same thing where it's not
allowing the rook and getting the d1 so
it's all the same and look at that draw
it is a draw right there so yes so today
or in draw mode right now they were in
drugs so that means we are three two
twos a diddy in the lead right right so
all they need is one more win and they
can't lose okay the best we can hope for
is a it's a draw we do have we do have a
fake point in Newman chendo what do you
mean a fake point well I'm counting that
already okay so what is that saying
don't count the chickens before they
hatch losers losers say that alright you
got it you got to know when when you got
a win eight three games in progress I
mean I would so let's see this is uh-oh
4 2 is 4 2 is over 4 2 is over black
wins Black has checkmated white on board
- and that means that your ghena copia
has defeated Ashish Panda but we got the
scores wrong last year so God knows what
you never know you never we might be we
might already have one this man the kids
like Kathy and the kids look sad I mean
last year we announced a win for Zig
Diddy before we found out a st. Louis
wins all right now it looks like st.
Louis can no longer win because suck did
he has achieved four points so the best
st. Louis can do it appears is tie the
match match draw so okay so iris iris
came through really big with a big win
last year hopefully she knows as the
team captain she should know what the
score is and I don't know how how iris
can win this game today so white has the
to passed pawns and here they come
obviously we only 15 seconds also oh no
way to up Bishop back Bishop back you
just pray I wrists down ticking away she
makes a move Bishop b4 this could be the
end of us so we still have a pizza party
I said say isn't the pizza party is for
the winning will get there at some point
oh no yeah this doesn't look good for
st. Louis you know the pressures got to
be on iris but here comes the check to
seal the deal that does it
fork fork big board hey might as well
played a mate right yep no reason to
resign yeah Mouse lips it happens and
iris is not happy look at she's just
resigned and that's that's the walk-off
homer right there Diddy has achieved
five points five to two is the live
score and there is still one game
remaining let's head on over to our
board seven with newman shen as he his
game continues against Nika newman has
the black pieces and he looks like we'll
get our consolation
jury you never know this this could
clinch the match for us you never know
it strongly appears that zag Diddy is
leading five to two if you weren't
watching last year we were wrong
I think iris came in he was like what we
won yeah we got both shishas and odd
he's mistaken last year so yeah never
know now this guy has achieved the
stalemate position
why do you didn't go to the Oh cuz they
be gonna corny get made it oh right
Newman's happy at least well that does
it all of the games have ended the final
match score we want to congratulate as
AG Diddy
five to three they have they sent their
best they regain their composure after
last year and we fielded a new team
mostly and took our tried-and-true USA
Chess Club members to town Mike what are
your thoughts on this we got the last
victory
unfortunately April Fool's has come and
gone so I'm thinking this score is
actually going to hold up this year
unfortunately for better or for worse
Selena had that nice position and
couldn't get the the win or the draw
that one really hurt us well I'd like to
talk with our team captain here possible
hopefully we'll get I reside on here in
the studio or one of our members to give
us some kind of insight into what's
going on up there because one thing I
noticed all of those players on our team
are friends and they're all very happy
and at least the atmosphere is lively up
in the room you know the is a giddy team
is playing in a hotel yeah but the
question is are they friends it doesn't
really matter because they had the
better result today I guess so
well it is a chess school it's like
diddy chess school so I would imagine
there's some camaraderie maybe maybe
rivals but still come together as team
play and play as a team
because you saw at the end you know they
were kind of in draw mode in the in the
closer competitions and got the two
draws and that's the difference you know
what they were too lost that whole
different story
I've been informed that our good
correspondent Dennis LaRue don't worry
he's not a part of the show today he is
being sent to go get the captain
iris ow who you know a lot of times you
don't like to interview the person who
has lost because it's so crushing it's
like tell us about your loss
but today we're gonna have to do that
the captain so I never lose captain's
gotta take the blame I think when that
lorry yeah we were gonna do that no
matter what but while we're waiting for
our captain of the st. Louis team big
congratulations so there's like did
these chests cool
hey we'll do it again next year the
rubber match huh yeah love it love it
coming up next for the st. Louis chess
club broadcast we have a couple of big
vent events that you should know about
first of all we're having the st. Louis
norm Congress it's six days of a chess
tournament two fields actually going on
we're gonna have a grandmaster norm
section and an International Master norm
section these tournaments have
up-and-coming names in them where if a
player achieves a certain performance
say six and a half out of a possible
what is it mean then they get a
grandmaster norm you get three norms you
achieve a certain rating boom you're a
grandmaster that's how it happens the
age-old question how do you become a
Grandmaster so you should watch the st.
Louis norm Congress and find out it runs
from May 16th to may the 21st
I'll have the honor of hosting along
with Grandmaster Alexander Linderman for
the very first time and we'll be
bringing abbreviated coverage to you on
the st. Louis Chess Club YouTube channel
and us chess champs calm once again that
begins on May and 16th and it runs
through the 21st so you never know what
you're gonna see at the norm Congress
and not everybody always achieved it but
not someone always achieves a norm in
these tournaments but we will have
prizes we will have a champion of the
norm Congress regardless and the players
love love this because all they have to
do is get the score they don't have to
worry about anything else like Oh Who am
I gonna play in this round the pairings
are already made round right they know
they know what color are they're gonna
get for each round they know
if they perform all they have to do is
hit that score and you get annoying you
know they don't have to worry about who
you know how many Federation players I'm
gonna play or anything it's all just set
out for them to achieve achieve their
desired norm yeah and so that's gonna be
a lot of fun that st. Louis chess club
has two normal tournaments each year we
have the norm Congress and the first
part of the year and then the
Invitational we call it in the later
part of the year and we'll be
broadcasting that later on this year as
well
all right now we do have our st. Louis
team captain in the studio so we're
gonna be right back in just a moment
with the captain iris ow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
alright welcome back we're here with the
team captain Arizona everybody wants to
know the answer to this question what
was the result of the match today well
we lost Oh
so it's official huh that's official
shucks so we didn't get like all the
results wrong all the bad news was
actually bad news for us all right you
want to briefly go over your matches a
team captain of the st. Louis
Archbishop's I know what it's like to be
on the losing end of a big big match and
never fun never fun but guess what
there's always next year we're going
back to the final four to play Armenia
and who knows maybe next year we can
lead our team back against Zack Diddy
and get the job done okay so yeah we've
won the world championship last year we
lost last year and now you know we'll be
all right
so all right let's check it out you had
the black pieces in this game and you
start with the Sicilian yeah so this is
kind of like a setup that I learned and
I basically played against like all the
close Sicilians which may or may not be
not the best yes I was a little
criticized of this move well no it's a
setup right because it's you want to
take control of the d4 square and also
in the normal setups where you play like
East six and d5 instead of E 5 and D 6
then oftentimes F 4 F 5 it's really
annoying but here it's harder to do just
the drawback is you know D 5 becomes
weak and right yeah and it gets F 4 in
anyway and I think a nice day was a
weird move but I don't know why he
didn't just play 92 I guess right yeah
his knight would look a lot lot better
on that square but alright I guess he's
got plans
so here I thought it was just fine like
I liked my position you know I have
eventual I can expand on the queenside
a6 b5 or playoff 5 and then he played
this g4 move and I was like it's going
on yeah I guess it was a portion f5 yeah
so basically I either have to take on a4
or play f5 and I couldn't get f5 to work
the way I wanted to it might be okay but
I felt that when all the things were
traded off it should favor white so I
just took this and here so I spent a
long time instead of 95 I really wanted
to play d5 but the thing was I wasn't
sure like well I know I I know I can I
can do that just let's say he does a
normal move he's not gonna take because
I think that's okay I think the most the
problem is let's say he plays a normal
of like Queen d2 then what's my next
move because well I don't really want
that pawn there because then he might
play rook e1 e 594 and I don't have my
Queen side expansion is probably slower
than his and the and if I take on e4
once his Knight gets to e4 I think it
becomes really annoying because again f6
the f6 square is weak just like it
normally is but I think so but knowing
what happened in the game I should have
played d5 at some point maybe 95 was
okay and then next move I should have
played d5 so yeah I mean that's a dream
of every a Sicilian player g5 yet see
now like f6 is a really big hole which
that's why I was really reluctant to
play d5 because then he has an e4 square
to get in but
96 is probably bad because after 95 I
started to realize that I don't really
know what you expand it yeah but the
thing is it doesn't really go anywhere
it says you're doing ok 91 I don't know
I don't know about 91
I wasn't every move I thought he would
play Knight of 6 in sack upon like go
back look after a 5 maybe after a 5 like
every new I don't know how good it is
but just because then Bishop h6 and I
moved my rook and then Knight g4 and so
I have to I probably have to play Bishop
takes g4 rook takes f6 Bishop takes d1
row takes d1 and he has the two bishops
in my d6 pawn is hanging and I just
thought this is so bad maybe it's not as
bad as I thought but it's definitely not
something I want to play okay decide to
capture but yeah he I wasn't sure how to
avoid it
yeah he never really did it so but the
thing was that's why I spent a lot of
time cuz I was really worried he was
gonna do that and after 91 I realized
like Knight f6 is gonna be really strong
leaks move so I kind of had to okay but
now he's got that e4 square that you
were yeah but since he played 91 if he
goes back he wastes some time and I have
enough time to play like night of five
and maybe my pieces can start to get
active okay that was my idea
here and yeah I started getting low on
time and I wasn't sure what to do
Brooksie one is probably rook c8 it's
probably really bad wait can you go back
after 93 I think if I had more time I
would have considered like night of five
more because I do get the double pawns
but at least my pieces start to become
active that's what the computer wants me
to play so yes it just it looks weird
but I think if I had more time to
evaluate it I would have realized the
other option was way worse and this is
probably my only hope
cuz rook c8 I was afraid he would play
d4 right so that's why I wanted to give
my knight of square then when he did
this I was like oh no yeah because if I
play Bishop takes the nygean yeah that's
what I wanted you to play because in the
actual game now he's got this deep but
okay once they put a knight on d6 his
deep on isn't going anywhere which that
was a good I thought I had no choice
because if I had played Bishop takes and
then Knight g4 and then Bishop g7 he can
choose to play Knight f6 now or later
and then he's gonna probably gonna take
what the pawn and yeah this doesn't look
very good yeah okay yeah I think it
shows wisely then so then yeah Bishop
before I thought was really annoying
because now my Knights never getting to
f5 and so I got down to like a minute
and I decided h6 was like my last chance
because he was gonna play Knight g4
Knight f6 I had to do something okay I
was wondering why you were playing h6
here but it kind of lets you off the
hook h6 or h5 I wasn't sure but after
okay after age six he definitely should
have taken red but now because after h4
h5 now his knight is it's really hard
for him to get you have six and so he
has a more space but I don't know like
what he's gonna and he's more active
piece but I don't know what he's gonna
do about it
like once I put my knight on d6 the
thing is with increment I can make these
move really fast and I get more time to
think
right yeah yeah so it looks like yeah
yeah the thing was I didn't want to take
a draw because I think we were losing
the match at that point right but it's
gonna be really it's really hard yeah so
I was trying to infiltrate with my queen
somehow and he let me which I thought
was surprising like I let I let him take
upon but I knew is a risk but I had to
take that risk right yeah we team
competitions yeah you got to think
whether you're greater good and I was
really surprised he didn't take my pawn
yeah yeah what's he afraid of I think he
didn't like that I could check and then
play e4 and suddenly my bishop becomes
active his king is kind of weak which I
guess makes sense no interesting so he
does have a tactic here though it looks
like if you push here Kohlberg takes f7
looks like they don't even care the
problem is my e pawn is going really
fast now because before was blockaded
and once you let me get out then I think
all three results are possible oh maybe
maybe maybe uh Georgie they're their
team captain made the white the right
decision here and just retreated back
and the thing was I I think at some
point I could have just sat and waited
but I kind of miss evaluated what I was
trying to do and also I tried you are to
win I think I should have just sat and
it looks like the big diddy team really
knew the match situation because as soon
as they've got up two to one they
started taking draws another board so
I'm sure George you knew where that draw
would probably clinch this match so so
that's why he's just content with yeah
and that was really bad because what I
failed to realize is that at some point
he's gonna defend his D pawn in place c5
and I'm gonna be in big trouble
yeah he's got the two monsters coming at
you
yeah like this is just so bad so you put
up a heck of a fight you know and and
good for you for trying to fight on for
the win and what looked like a you know
a drawn or even losing position but you
knew the you knew the the game score the
match scoring
yeah wanted to uh yeah but the thing was
we were really close to winning this
match because my sister had away she had
a winning position and then she messed
it up yeah well too bad for a team st.
Louis
we're gonna go to break and then put a
bow on the episode stay tuned
[Music]
you
all right welcome back as we close the
show cumference had a long day
apparently Bensimon and Mike comer here
at the mat the return match on the
Internet as today in chess presents st.
Louis vs Diddy we want to congratulate
there's a Diddy chess school because
they did pull it out five to three as we
just heard 100% official no fuli's I
mean we talked about the st. Louis norm
Congress coming up here as our next
event that's semi local I guess the next
broadcast from around the world will
actually be before that and it's the
first leg of the 2019 grand chest or the
biggest one yet this year there's going
to be 12 members on this tour 12
competitors in Cote d'Ivoire Bobby Jon
for viewers of last year you remember we
did do this tournament with 10 of
Africa's best players in Cote d'Ivoire
and it turned out so good they put it on
the grand chest tour now bossom amine
the best player in africa egypt's number
one by far he will still be in this
event as a wild card but he'll be joined
by the likes of Magnus Carlsen last
year's grand chess grand chest Tour
champion Hikaru Nakamura MBL Dingle Erin
Wesley so and more it's gonna be so much
fun it's gonna be several days of rapid
and blitz the first leg of the grand
chest or let's see who's gonna get the
first for Santa it corresponds with the
protest leagues finals oh yeah San
Francisco so guess guess who can't play
in San Francisco to help the Archbishop
south oh great master Wesley so the 2017
MVP of the league
well these chess calendar is just packed
man you gotta you gotta take those shoes
huh yeah so for more information on that
be sure to check out grande chest or dot
org well today's been a good time even
though it wasn't the result that we had
hoped for but when you lay it on the
line you got to be prepared to lose I
know you're a betting man might come
hopefully you didn't lose a lot of
today it'd be very tragic event on
things that I'm kind of involved in that
would never do that got up got an
important question of course I'm joking
but important question luck did he
changed up nearly their entire roster
this year and they did a good thing they
want our team as I've said has so much
camaraderie and they were victorious
last year do you think you want to
change it up for next year you want to
field the same team knowing that they
know what they they're facing well I
mean we could have invited Luke Yee
everybody's favorite or jernej ern pari
Arjun Arjun who know his real name
so maybe well I like the team we have no
substitutions necessary as long as
they're all available at a date we can
arrive on next year we're bringing the
whole team back and one spectacular it's
good to hear and I'm sure they're happy
to hear it
barring any scheduling conflicts so I
want to give a shout out to the world's
greatest production B team streaming the
show today the technical director Danny
Machuca audio and graphics is Isaac
Franz we want to thank Dennis LaRue from
the street getting our special guest in
here oh hey he's not too far away
writing the pizza huh he's got pizza oh
he's a good guy Dennis LaRue anyway
until next time we see you for the grand
chest or maybe alternate language and
st. Louis norm Congress in May he's the
most entertaining man in chest might
come er my name is Ben Simon and we say
so long from the show-me-state